Man darf die Schneekugel nicht schütteln,
sondern man muss sie auf den Kopf stellen,
warten, bis der Schnee zusammenkommt,
und dann umdrehen,
und dann schneit’s richtig.
Erwin Perzy III. kennt alle Geheimnisse
rund um die Schneekugel.
In dieser Werkstatt in Wien hat schon sein
Großvater, Erwin Perzy I., experimentiert.
Er war Mechaniker für
Chirurgie-Instrumente – und Erfinder.
Mit einer Glaskugel voll
Wasser wollte er eigentlich
das Licht für den Operationssaal verstärken.
Mein Großvater hat vor 121 Jahren
genau durch reinen Zufall
die Schneekugel erfunden.
Er hat in der Küche von
seiner Mutter Grieß gefunden,
hat den Grieß in dieses Wasser
hineingegeben, und der Grieß hat sich
mit Wasser angesoffen und ist
so ganz langsam zu Boden geschwebt.
Und wie er das gesehen hat,
hat er sich gedacht:
Das sieht aus, als ob es
in dieser Kugel schneit.
Und das war die Basisidee
für die Schneekugel.
In der Werkstatt fand sein
Großvater zudem eine Miniatur
der österreichischen
Wallfahrtskirche Mariazell.
Mit Schuhpaste bemalte er einen Sockel und
klebte die Kirche in die Mitte der Glaskugel.
Im Jahr 1900 ließ er sich die erste
Schneekugel der Welt patentieren.
Mit der Wiener Rezeptur rieseln
die Flocken besonders sanft.
Erst mein Vater hat dann die
Mischung hergestellt vom Schnee,
die wir heute noch verwenden.
Und das ist mein persönliches Geheimnis,
das weiß momentan nur ich.
Rund 200.000 Kugeln werden jedes Jahr
in der Wiener Manufaktur hergestellt.
Fast alle Einzelteile stammen
aus lokaler Produktion.
Die Figuren werden in Handarbeit gefertigt.
Dazu wird flüssiger Kunststoff in
Metallformen gegossen und gepresst.
Seit vergangenem Jahr arbeitet Familie
Perzy zusätzlich mit 3D-Druck.
Diese Daten werden dann
an den Drucker geschickt,
und der Drucker produziert dann
Schicht für Schicht die Figur.
Ein paar Pinguine, ein Engel.
Tochter Sabine Perzy II. führt seit Kurzem
den Betrieb in vierter Generation weiter –
als erste Frau in der Familiengeschichte.
Die Zukunft des Unternehmens sieht sie
positiv: Tradition ist bei den Kunden beliebt.
Zurück zum Ursprung – man will wissen,
was man konsumiert,
wo die Sachen herkommen, die man kauft.
Bei einer jeden Schneekugel, die dieses
Haus verlässt, lässt sich zurückverfolgen:
Wer hat das produziert?
Diese Kugel hat ein Gesicht,
und das sind wir, das ist meine Familie.
Auch Erwin Perzys Ehefrau bemalt
täglich mehrere Dutzend Kugeln.
Viele Kunden geben Motive in Auftrag.
Um gegenüber Nachahmern und
Billigproduzenten bestehen zu können,
setzt die Familie auf Originalität und
beweist bei der Umsetzung Humor –
auch in der Corona-Krise.
Also, das ist die berühmteste Schneekugel
vom Jahr 2020.
Unsere Schneekugel mit dem Toilettenpapier
war der Verkaufsschlager:
Die Leute sind auf der Gasse
draußen Schlange gestanden,
um so eine Schneekugel zu bekommen.
Direkt neben der Werkstatt befindet sich das
familieneigene Schneekugel-Museum.
Die Wiener Schneekugel
ist ein wahrer Exportschlager.
Sogar drei ehemalige US-Präsidenten haben
ein exklusives Exemplar im Regal stehen –
so wie etwa diese Kugel
der Familie Obama, ein Gastgeschenk
einer Wienerin für das Weiße Haus.
Mehr als 350 Motive gehören
mittlerweile zum Sortiment.
Wenn man da reinschaut,
ist das eine richtig schöne heile Welt.
Und das ist meine Welt
seit mehr als vierzig Jahren.
Und mit Sicherheit der
schneesicherste Ort Österreichs.